bethesda opened the showcase with a
dramatic gameplay demo for redfall and
closed it with todd howard showing us
how deep the rabbit hole goes on
starfield and we also got a sneak peek
at upcoming expansions for elder scrolls
online and fallout 76 here to break it
all down for us is the man the myth
legend himself pete hines from bethesda
pete how are you i'm great good to see
you good to see you as well so about a
month ago you all announced some delays
for both red fall and starfield so i
wanted to give you a chance to like tell
us a little bit about the
decision-making process for that
absolutely look with all the time that
goes into a game it would be foolish to
rush it out the door before it's ready i
think we have continued to sort of
examine how we think about
games and making sure that they are
going to meet our players expectations
obviously the last two years have really
challenged us from a development
standpoint
how we work now
largely remotely while a lot of our
folks are not back in the office and you
know that has an impact i also think
we've been thinking about things like
release dates and when do we give those
out and and how do we make sure we give
one out that that we actually hit and
don't have to change later so
it's not something we undertake lightly
but at the end of the day i think what
our fans expect what xbox fans what
bethesda fans expect is a is a high
quality game and and we want to do
everything we can to give our teams the
time to to fully realize the the games
they're making yeah and i think that's
what it's all about right like
delivering an amazing experience for the
players out there and so speaking of
games we're just going to jump into it
we're going to start with how the
showcase started which sounds good red
fall now before we even get into the
game arcane's making the game and i want
you to talk a little bit about the
pedigree of arcane just in case people
don't know sure these folks over there
they're doing their thing arcane studios
is known for really amazing immersive
sims they do any number of things
if you if you play games of theirs
dishonored dishonored to pray there's a
lot of common threads you'll find in
them they create um really amazing
believable worlds i think that's a big
part of their game is is when you're in
dunwall or you're up on a space station
and pray that it it feels believable
there's a reason why things are the way
they are they're also a big believers in
systems based as opposed to scripted so
they they really embrace player freedom
and sort of giving players the tools to
decide you figure out how you want to
complete this mission or get through
this area we're not going to tell you
how we're just going to give you tools
and then give you the freedom to go and
do but you know there's great characters
and interesting story they bring a lot
of different elements and then really
let the player create the experience
they want and that's what it's all about
gamers have taken many games and made it
their own and i think the fact that
arcane is making the game with that in
mind is super important now how similar
or dissimilar would you say this game
red fall is from the other i mean look
on the surface it's a first person
shooter that you can play solo or with
you know up to four players and so
immediately you might say well it's not
a single player game so it must be
wildly different and and don't get me
wrong there's absolutely ways in which
it is different but i think when folks
play the game and even when they see
more of the game i think they'll start
to see all of those things about an
arcane game that they that they love and
appreciate you know why it's won
multiple action game of the year awards
for dishonor for dishonored 2 is their
ability to to bring all of those things
together really high level of polish and
and let folks experience it and so i
think all those things we talked about
if you want to play a game by yourself
and get a great arcane story you can
absolutely do that in red fall but you
can also do things that you haven't been
able to do in an arcane game like
experience it with friends and and find
out sort of how the whole can become
greater than the sum of the parts like
playing it off of each um character's
abilities you saw some of that in the
demo we showed you know that i think the
more the people appreciate that you
almost are going to want to try and play
red fall a couple of different ways you
might want to play it by yourself a
little bit play it with others and it's
a game that allows you to do either or
both of those things however you see fit
i'm glad you talked about playing with
friends because i'm taking applications
for friends to help me get through red
fall
can can i put my name on that list
it'd be an honor pete keep me on that
list all right we need to go explore red
fall together i'm excited i can't wait
for that and so let's talk a little bit
more about the game now um you know
between the trailer that we saw last
year at the reveal as well as this one
that we just saw
i feel like red fall reminded players of
other co-op shooters like left 4 dead
for example what makes red fall unique
um again it's one of those things like
if you if you watch just like combat
footage you might look at left 4 dead or
back for blood or any of these things
and go oh i see multiple characters
facing a bunch of enemies and like so
it's the same game but i think that's
that would be doing a disservice that
it's all of the things that take place
in between the combat as well as the
combat itself sort of combining
different skills and abilities in in the
way that you do you know layla dropping
down an elevator using her her powers
that jacob can use to get up top on a on
a roof and provide cover you know you
have different characters who play roles
really well how you choose to use
bribone um the robot all of those things
come into again allowing the players not
to say here's a set of rules and you can
only use like no here's just some stuff
that you can go off into this amazing
sort of dynamic ever changing world and
sort of experience and explore for
yourself and you come back the next day
and it'll look and feel like a different
experience even though you're in the
exact same part of the game i mean i
think those are the kinds of things that
arcane does that really um bring that
sort of extra special element that makes
their game so compelling yeah compelling
and fresh so i'm excited for a red fall
and you said it here on for everyone to
see that we're going to be playing
together so i'm going to hold you to
that absolutely
all right can't wait awesome so let's
talk about elder scrolls online now i
wanted to talk about the team philosophy
because i hear that the team is actually
banned from saying things like now is
the perfect time to my least favorite
saying is there's never been a better
time to play a game like we all say that
yes games always get better we know that
the thing that we love about where elder
scrolls online is is is going is their
ability to continually
refresh the experience for players
provide new experiences like going to
high aisle a place they've never been in
an elder scrolls game it does a lot of
things like story and intrigue there's a
lot of politics in high aisle different
factions and and the the conflict that's
going on there and again a way that you
can jump in and play by yourself and
experience it
by yourself even though it's an mmo but
the real special sauce of elder scrolls
online is our amazing community they're
so welcoming they're so helpful you know
if you need a little bit of help if you
need a lot of help
they're there for you to help explain to
you know to make sure you have a fun
experience and honestly like that is
such a huge part for an online game of
creating an environment where anybody no
matter whether you just started playing
or you've been playing for eight years
can have a good experience no matter how
you decide to engage with it i love that
you mentioned that a community is such
as you mentioned is such a huge part of
any online game and so for players who
may not have played elder scrolls who
are like you said looking to jump in to
know that they have that community
backing them that's going to help them
guide them in their journey is super
exciting so but i want to talk about
fallout a little bit okay huge milestone
recently 25 years of fallout it can rent
a car even now at this point right we're
talking about it all right so this has
to mean something uh super special today
absolutely and and look
we are as aware of anybody like this
this franchise did not start with
bethesda it's one that we took on along
the way and our intent is not just to to
pay homage to like bethesda fallout like
no we mean all fallout because what this
series has done what it what it meant to
us as players when we went and played
those games played the original fallout
fallout 2 um and then what the franchise
has become and sort of growing and
finding an even you know a new audience
with fallout 3 fallout 4 fallout new
vegas fallout 76 is something we really
want to celebrate and honestly that you
know what's going on in fallout 76 with
the pit and your ability to continue to
push the boundaries in an online game of
story and meaningful player choice and
as you're going along making decisions
that kind of um matter and have a real
impact i think is is important in the
evolution of fallout 76 and just
honestly how far that game has come from
its launch like we're keenly aware of
how that launch went but we are also
keenly aware of the incredible amount of
effort and dedication from all of our
teams across bethesda to say like we
believe in this thing and we want to
give the fans more of what they want and
the kind of experiences that they want
and where fallout 76 is now is truly
remarkable when you go back and look at
sort of where we were and how far we've
come in and honestly how much cool stuff
is in store in the pit it's it's going
to be super fun excited to jump in and
again that's one of those things that
i'm sure you guys tribute to the
community giving that feedback you know
that that 76 community again not just in
the game but
what they do for for each other to
support other folks in the community
what they have done to raise funds for
worthwhile causes like it's not just an
amazing group of gamers it's an amazing
group of human beings and honestly one
that we're honored to interact with and
be a part of every day i love that pete
before you make me cry we're going to
move on to star field all right okay all
right so let's talk about it starfield
ended the show i gotta say watching the
trailer
breathtaking it's one of those things
from the different locations and just
seeing the difference between that moon
versus the populated city just amazing
the dog fighting uh the just everything
was so awesome the team really outdid
themselves it's one of those things
about a bethesda games studios game that
i always love and it's been the case
honestly since you know i i worked on
morrowind and oblivion and all those
games that you know we talked about and
ev for every single one you cannot pin
people down to oh it's about this
because it's not like ultimately what
those games are are massive sandboxes
where they give players just ridiculous
amounts of freedom to say you go figure
out what kind of game you want to play
and what kind of experience you want to
have because that's what this game is
about it's not us prescribing and saying
you have to do these things and like no
it's about creating this huge
sandbox with over a thousand planets so
you can completely explore and say yeah
but you don't have to like it's entirely
up to you to figure out what what is fun
for me do i want story do i want to join
factions do i want to you know build
outposts and gather resources to build
more cool stuff the team really puts all
of those tools in the players hands and
step back and says
now it's time for you to tell the story
of starfield which is your story which
is going to be different than mine which
is going to be different than everybody
else's and i think that's that's really
where the magic of a bethesda game
studios game happens speaking about the
scope of everything todd said that this
is what an epic rpg
is what what does bethesda define an
epic rpg as i think again it's it's sort
of leaning into look there's a lot of
folks who take a lot of different
approaches on what is an open world mean
and bethesda game studios always pushes
themselves to the most freedom and least
limitations right where the items in the
world are all real things you walk into
a store and there's a bunch of weapons
or whatever like that's not just art on
a countertop like you could pick those
up you could steal them and run out of
it you can create chaos like we don't
want to put too many limits on what the
player is or isn't allowed to do we love
it when players say i wonder what
happens if and then they try it and then
they get to see like oh my lord chaos
ensued and it was insanity everybody was
shooting at me and like that's i think
the beauty of bethesda game studios and
the and the number of ways that they
push for you to explore that right it's
not just one it's
you could spend thousands of hours doing
nothing but shipbuilding and like focus
that as all you're about and that's okay
but you could also be about exploring
every planet and finding all of the good
and that's okay or you could just play
the main story and be like i want a kind
of experience that i'm guided through so
that i kind of get to see stuff and i
might stop here and there oh there's a
cool side quest that i got but you know
i want something that sort of leads me
through because i'm a little you know it
can be a little daunting to say you can
go do whatever i want like oh i don't
know what i should do so some folks want
a little bit of a guided path or to
understand where the fun is and no
approach is wrong like for me that's
epic because it says we aren't putting
any limits on what you can or can't do
we're going to set you loose and just
sit back and watch the the beauty that
you create with your own stories and the
way that you solve problems or choose to
spend your time in this world we've
created i love that and i you know what
you said about um you know those moments
that maybe you experience that i don't
like those are some of the best moments
if i think back to playing rpgs when i'm
discussing with my friends oh did you
see that no i didn't see it where did
you see it and having them go out and
find it so i think that's going to be
one of those we talk about that a lot
that sort of water cooler moment like
you come in the next day and you talk to
everybody about what you did and you
were like wait i did that quest but i
did this completely different thing and
you sort of start to appreciate all of
the choices that you could have made you
didn't even realize were an option like
oh i didn't even think about doing that
like oh yeah i just ran in and stole his
ship and shot all of his crew members
and took off like you can do that like
oh yeah you can do anything like that i
think that is
um a special part of the bethesda game
studios game and and when we say epic
rpg we mean all of the stories all of
them all right you just gave me some
ideas for stealing people's ships uh so
i appreciate that uh that's gonna be top
on the list to do in starfield now um we
saw quite a bit of combat and action in
the game that seems to also be in in
addition to exploring and everything
that seems to be another huge focus of
that absolutely i mean you know look if
you look at a game like skyrim which
like everybody's played skyrim at this
point
it can you know a combat is a big part
of that unless you decide it's not like
if you're one of those folks that says
actually i'm gonna do the alchemy thing
and i just go off and pick flowers and
make potions and like
live another life in another world this
way then combat isn't part of it but
look we know in an epic rpg there's
always bad people they you know shooting
at you sometimes you got to return fire
and there's a lot of fun to be had there
and so you know providing a lot of
different skills that sort of determine
how good you are in combat combined with
all the different weapons in the game
and then you layer in ship combat and
all these other things it starts to sort
of paint a picture of just how
broad or how deep the rabbit hole goes
it's going to be so impressive um and
you touched on it a little bit and i
want to talk about it because this was
watching the the video the demo on what
i saw and it really caught my eyes
around the ship um it's not just getting
in the ship and that's your ship there's
so much behind it
a little bit yeah like every ship is
customizable to the nth degree and not
just like cosmetically i want my ship to
look like this or look like that though
obviously that's totally the thing that
you could do if all you care about is
cosmetics but it goes much deeper than
that in terms of like what kind of
shield you have what kind of weapons you
have like what kind of ship are you
building what do you want it to be good
at what trade-offs are you willing to
make or not and then the other part of
it is of course well you can't just like
it's a spaceship those aren't cheap so
you have to figure out like how am i
going to do this where do i get the
resources to build this stuff what kind
of you know skills do i need to level up
to improve different parts of my ship
beyond you know what i could do without
those skills so there's a lot of again
choices in terms of you get to decide
that how much you want to put into that
or not do you just want to give somebody
money for the parts that you want you
want to build it all of those things are
are sort of part of the fun of deciding
how much do you want to interact with
this and how do you want to interact
with it absolutely i mean just as you
mentioned the scope the level of player
agency something that i feel like is
going to just make starfield such a
special experience so between red fall
esl fallout 76 and starfield you all are
just
coming yeah we got a few games coming
out it's gonna be so great um pete thank
you so much for stopping by thanks for
having me of course of course pete now
coming up we'll hear from our friends
around the world including squanch games
obsidian entertainment playground games
and of course xbox fans like you but
first let's hear from the creators of
one of the world's most popular battle
royale games